[موسيقى]
الارجنتين المرشح للفوز بكاس العالم جنبا
الى جنب مع البرازيل الثالث في تصنيف
الفيفا العالمي الارجنتين القيمه
التسويقيه للاعبيها تقترب من 750 مليون
يورو والمونديال الاخير لمصر كل
هذا جانبا الصقور الخضر ينقضون عليهم في
مباراههم الاولى بمونديال قطر وينهون
المباراه بهدفين بهدف ويكتبون فوزا
للتاريخ عن جداره واستحقاق
فوز ينهي سلسله الانتصارات المتتاليه
للارجنتين عندها 36 فوزا ويحبطوا ميسي
ورفاقه ويصعب عليهم مهمه العبور للدوري
المقبل في البطوله صالح الشهري سالم
الدوسري هدفان في خمس دقائق يقلبان الكفه
والموازين لصالح الاخضر السعودي وخلفهم خط
دفاع في قمه انضباطه التكتيكيكي وحارس
مرمى بطل يدعم محمد العويس
ويؤمن بالفوز ويقدم
انها مباراه لا تحصل كل يوم ولا كل شهر
ولا كل سنه ولا ربما كل عقد بالامس شاهدنا
التاريخ
[موسيقى]
فرحه كبيره تعبر عنها الجماهير السعوديه
بعد فوز منتخبها على منتخب الارجنتين
بنتيجه 2-1 كما نشاهد هنا في مدينه الخبر
الجماهير كلها خرجت الى شوارع للاحتفال
بهذا الفوز التاريخي منذ انطلاق صادره
النهايه حتى ساعات المساء والجماهير كلها
موجوده في الشوارع احتفالا في هذا الفوز
التاريخ التاريخ
العب
يا ولد خل فرصه
[موسيقى]
جدا جميله من المنتخب واعضاء منتخب وافراد
المنتخب فردا فردا انها ان المنتخب
والدوله والملك وليه الملك كلهم الحمد لله
بفوز الجميل هذا اليوم متفائل مباراه
المكسيك بولندا
كمان والسعوديه جده وقدود
كيف شفت المباراه اليوم مباراه الحمد لله
يعني ما كانت متوقعه بس هذا اللي يستهتر
في السعوديين هذا اللي هذا اللي يجيه هذا
اللي يجيء يقول ميسي اقول ميسي والله
انا اسف والله احب ميسي بس اليوم انا
سعودي اسول
ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
اكيد قبل المباراه كنت خايف كنت متوقعها
نتيجه كبيره متى حسيته منتخب السعودي
بس من بعد الحمد لله بعد ما الغوه الشوط
الثاني ادينا ممتاز وما خيب ظن الناس
الضغط
[موسيقى]